let's go to
some difficult topics uh you wrote In
the book about your experience with some
very low points in
government uh you've been attacked quite
a bit uh one of the ones that stands out
is the accusations of collusion with
Russia and you tell in the book in
general this whole story this whole J on
a personal level on a sort of big
political level uh can you tell me some
aspects of the story
sure so to give the listeners some
context um and people remember this now
it's been kind of Swept Away uh because
it turned out not to be true was that
after president Trump uh won the
election in
2016 instead of the media saying we were
wrong because again everyone thought he
had zero chance of of winning they said
okay well we couldn't have been wrong it
must have been the Russians who worked
with him and so at first when this
started coming up I thought this was
ridiculous I mean I I was very
intimately involved with the operations
of the campaign I was running the
finance of the campaign I was running
the digital media of the campaign I was
running the the the the the the schedule
for the campaign and I knew that on most
days we had trouble like you know
working coordinating with ourselves you
know let alone you know you know
collaborating with another government
and or colluding as they called it and
so um we did a great job I think as an
underdog campaign very leanly staffed
and then they said that you know we were
working with the Russians and so
um at the time I didn't take it too
seriously because I knew there was no
truth to it but it was amazing to me to
start seeing all of these institutions
whether it was CNN The Washington Post
New York Times these were news
organizations that I grew up having a
lot of respect for taking these
accusations so seriously and then
working themselves up in order to um in
order to just cover it for two years
then as a result you had a special
counsel you had a a house investigation
a senate investigation and I personally
spent about I think over 20 hours uh
just you know testifying before uh these
different committees again spent
millions of dollars of out of my own
pocket on my legal fees uh to make sure
I was well represented and the reason I
did that was because I saw in Washington
it was like a sick game right it's
almost like you know even though there
was no underlying problems to the
accusation um I felt like this is one of
those things where they're going to try
to catch you and then if you step on the
line they catch you with one
misrepresentation they're going to try
to put you in jail or Worse to you know
and so for me that was a big concern so
and it was amazing mean my my my poor
mom you know I told her to stop you know
reading whatever I said I promise you we
didn't do anything wrong it's good but
you know she'd call me and say well you
know our friends were you on the upper
side we talking with Chuck Scher says
Jared's going to jail you know we know
for sure that he colluded with the
Russians and this is like a leading
Senator saying things like this and so
it was just interesting for me to see
how the whole world could believe
something and be talking about it that I
knew with 1,00% certainty was just not
true and so seeing that play out was
very very hard obviously you know I was
accused of a lot of things there were
times in Washington I was radioactive I
remember one weekend um you know it was
all over CNN you know the people they
panels on CNN like the news organization
that I grew up thinking was like the
number one trusted name for news in the
world talking about how I'd committed
treason because I met with an ambassador
and said we'd like to hear your
perspective on what you think the policy
should be in Syria where there was a big
Civil War happening and and and Isis and
a lot of different things so it was
quite a crazy time in that regard but
luckily again we we were able to fight
through it it was a major distraction
for our Administration uh I think we
were able to kind of stay focused on the
objectives and the policies uh but it
was a crazy time and I I learned a lot
uh from that experience it's crazy how
just an accusation can be viral and can
just go one of the things that worries
me is the effect on your mind the
psychology of it to make sure it doesn't
make you cynical like people that trying
to do stuff those kinds of stories that
can destroy their mind so one of the
things I'd love to sort of understand
you who kind of rolled in from the
business world and all a sudden the the
entire world from CNN to everybody is
accusing you of colluding with the
Russians like what do you uh like when
you're sitting at
home how do you keep a Calm Mind a clear
mind an optimistic one that doesn't
become cynical and actually just keep
trying to push on and do stuff in the
world yeah so it was a surreal
experience um I would say number one is
I I felt very confident that I hadn't
done anything wrong so you I'd always
tell my lawyer like you know the good
news is I've got a good fact problem
right like I need a good lawyer to get
me through it but it's it's much easier
to be a good lawyer if you have a very
innocent client and so you know the fact
that I knew that I didn't have I I
didn't believe that I had any legal
liability helped me kind of
intellectually separate the challenge I
need to do to fight through it from it
and then I just basically said like you
I'd had hardship earlier in my life
where I dealt with the situation with my
father and what I realized there is that
you can't really spend energy on the
things that you don't control all you
can do is spend your time and energy
worrying about what you can control and
then how do you react to the things that
you have there and so it took a lot of
uh a lot of discipline it took a lot of
strength and again I give my wife uh
vonka and even Donald a lot of credit
for um you know for kind of having my
during that time and and and you know
encouraging me just to kind of fight
through it um and then I also had to
make sure that I didn't allow that to
distract me from my job I felt like I
had an amazing opportunity in the White
House to make a difference in the world
and if I would have spent all my time
playing defense you know in politics
it's a Time duration game in business
you have whatever duration you set for
yourself in politics it's time duration
we had four years um every day with sand
through an hourglass my mindset was I
need to accomplish as much as I can in
these four years and and I guess the
traditional game that's played in
Washington is whether it's the media the
opposition uh their job is to distract
you and then try to stop you from being
as successful as you want to be and so
just fought through it and um wasn't
always fun but we we got through and and
thank God it's um it's something people
don't talk about and it has been amazing
to me just the lack of self-awareness
and and reflection of a lot of the
people who hyped this up for for two
years they don't think there was
anything wrong with it and and that's
uh interesting but you know my view is
we got through it it's good so it's in
the past and then I started moving to
the Future and that's really where I SP
yeah but I want to linger on it because
to me that has a really discouraging
effect on anyone who's trying to do
positive in the world like these kinds
of attacks are intense yeah I mean you
you say kind of one of the lessons you
learned is that you really have to be
perfect but I hate that to be the lesson
like I feel like you should be able to
do stupid stuff take big risks and like
people celebrate the big risks and not
try to weave gigantic stories over over
nothing I just want to kind of
understand the two aspects of this how
to not have such stories of so much legs
and the other is how to stay
psychologically strong so you kind of
waved it off that you didn't have a fact
problem but it can just have a effect in
your psyche yeah you seem to be pretty
stoic about the whole thing but like how
I mean just on the psychology side how
did you
stay uh calm and not become cynical
where you can continue to do stuff and
take big risks I didn't have a choice
what do you mean I mean I could have
spent every day feeling sorry for myself
for complaining or saying things aren't
fair but the the general way I looked at
it was that in life every opportunity
has a cost and you know you could look
at it and say maybe this was a massive
cost either in in dollars or in time or
in reputation or in or in um or in in
emotional drain but you could also say
that you know I had an opportunity to
work in the white house and I had an
opportunity to work on some of the
hardest challenges and you talk about
how that's not celebrated that is
something very different in the private
sector when you take on big challenges
that is celebrated in government when
you take on big challenges people want
to see it fail or they want to criticize
those people who are trying to take that
on and I think that's wrong and I think
that you know as a country we should be
thinking big we should be dreaming big
and we should be encouraging our
politicians to try and to fail more and
to you know to to go and to uh to take
on big things knowing that there's risk
of failing obviously we want them to
succeed not to fail but but let's take
on the big things let's try to do that
um so I think it's just very basic that
you know you're in a situation I've made
decisions I can't go back and change
decisions in the past I still felt you
know very blessed to be in the position
I was in and I knew that I just had to
work through it and like I said I was
very lucky to have you know support from
my wife and from my family uh and from
good friends again I I think i' I'd
chosen very good friends in life and my
friends were with me I had one friend
who who you know my lowest moment uh you
know got on the plane you lived in
Arizona got on a plane and came just to
have dinner with me to say just just
pick your head up I know you're down now
you're going to be fine just just fight
through that meant a lot to me and again
I I always think in my life you know you
don't learn as much from your successes
you don't learn as much from your high
points you learn the most about who you
want to be and how the world works from
your lowest moments and at those lowest
moments it just it made me better and it
taught me how to be a better friend to
people who are in tough
situations um and I tried to just get
get tougher and I tried to just get
better and work through
it